For the purpose
of this week,
we'll essentially be
resting in the 1930s,
essentially. It's a week's
worth of lecture dealing
with the Great Depression.
In October of 1929,
the stock market crashes,
and in a quick cascade of
events, Herbert
Hoover, then the President,
finds himself out of office
and Franklin Roosevelt is
elected
promising a New Deal,
a New Deal for America.
This week's lectures are
about the Great Depression,
Roosevelt's New Deal,
and several critical moments
and developments related to
the African American
experience. And I want you
to--We should all start with
a basic understanding of my
approach to the nineteen--to
the 1930s. If the twenties
can be understood as the
decade of the New Negro,
a new sort of social and
cultural and political world
view, the 1930s needs to be
understood as a decade of
retrenchment and political
advancement. We've seen
this before, going into the
late nineteenth century and
into the turn of the
twentieth century. And
we're just seeing a--a new
cycle of people gathering
themselves up and
articulating new visions and
new agendas, or new, new
methods to pursue on these
agendas for the future.
As far as retrenchment,
after so many cultural
celebrations and giddiness
of the Jazz
Age, as, you know,
the soldiers
that have returned,
the economic downturn made a
different--not new really,
but a different set of
priorities come to the
surface. The economy's
in tatters and African
Americans are the
hardest hit. And as far as
political
advancement is concerned,
along with the retrenchment
comes a range of political
responses to these
setbacks that demonstrate an
independence of spirit among
African Americans as far as
political possibilities.
Now this retrenchment and
political advancement, I
don't want to make too much
of a big deal. One can
identify these themes in any
particular decade or
moment in time of course.
But there is--there's
something very special I
think about the 1930s as
far as these aspects are
concerned. The 1930s forms
the backdrop for the modern
civil rights movement, that
movement that is popularly
thought of as
occurring from Brown v.
Board's decision in 1954 up
until King's assassination.
As you'll come to
understand very quickly,
that notion, boundedness of
the civil rights movement,
is really sort of discarded
by historians at this
point. And many historians
are talking about a long
civil rights movement, a
movement that predates the
Supreme Court decision and
goes back a decade or more.
I'll talk more about
this in a--in a week or so,
this phenomenon of the long
civil rights movement. But
regardless of where one
decides to sort of start the
civil rights movement,
you need to understand the
thirties is
clearly the seedbed,
the moment where a whole
new range of political
strategies are going
to be articulated,
and these grow out of
this moment of retrenchment,
trying to gathers--gather
oneself together in light of
economic despair. Now I
want to cover the story of
the 1930s. I
mean for any era,
there's too many different
stories one could tell,
but I want to explore the
themes of retrenchment and
political advancement in
the 1930s via a number of
stories. And this covers
this lecture and Wednesday's
lecture. I'll be talking
about the Black Cabinet,
the Scottsboro Boys,
the New Negro Alliance,
the National Negro Congress,
Marian Anderson and the
March on Washington
movement. This is a series
of different--different
kinds of events that really
marked, marked us right
through the 1930s with the
March on Washington movement
taking shape in 1941.
Throughout this whole era,
or this era--the umbrella
covering this era,
is the New Deal,
and that's what I want to
start off with very quickly,
so we have just a--sort of a
shared understanding of what
the New Deal is doing and
why it's important. So the
stock market
crashes in October,
'29. The country's
economically destabilized,
millions are thrown out
of work. Black and white
unemployment skyrocketed,
but blacks are particularly
hard hit. Job shortages and
old-fashioned racism combine
in such a way that a
familiar--familiar rallying
cry would be hear--heard at
job lines and such when a
black person showed
up. And I'm quoting,
"No jobs for niggers until
every white man has a job."
A time of
economic stress, good,
old-fashioned racism
makes itself known loud and
clear. Even in such
major cities like Atlanta,
some sixty-five percent of,
of employable blacks needed
public assistance. This
is economic devastation.
Hoover believed in
volunteerism and thought the
economy would turn itself
around without government
intervention. But by the
time he realized the scope
of the problem, he
found himself losing the
presidential
election. FDR's elected,
promises a New Deal. Now
the New Deal's a massive
federal experiment in
big government. It was an
alphabet soup, as, as
historians refer to it,
an alphabet
soup of agencies,
each representing
different forms of federal
intervention. And I'm
putting a--sev--a whole
bunch of them,
not all of them,
up on the board here, and
I'm going to very quickly go
through them to help you
understand the scope of the
change. You have the
FSA, or the Farm Security
Administration,
and the Agricultural
Adjustment--Adjustment
Administration,
two that are organizations
that are very important to
African Americans, aside
from being important to all
Americans, because
African Americans are still
predominantly--although
it's shifting--still
predominantly an
agricultural population.
They had the
National Recovery Act,
the NRA--that and I'll get
into a little more about the
NRA, it's very important,
in a few minutes--that among
other things establishes
the minimum wage,
or establishes minimum wages
is the better way to put
it. And there's a very
curious relationship with
African American--African
Americans and the jobs that
they hold. The Tennessee
Valley Authority and the
Rural--Rural
Electric--Electrification
Administration, these are
up here really to point out
what kind of radical change
the New Deal is really all
about. This is an era when
they're actually bringing
electricity for the first
time to large parts of the
country through, through the
TVA and hydroelectricity and
rural electrification. It's
a radical reordering of how
the country's going to
work. National Youth
Administration, NYA,
which as we'll see,
I'll talk briefly
about it later on,
is one of these many
administrations that has a
Negro division, and the
Negro division becomes
important. I mean I'll,
I'll--You can bookmark it
for the moment.
Civilian Conservation Corps,
the CCC, literally putting
mostly men to work by
digging ditches,
planting trees,
giving them some sort of job
to do so they can get some
wage from the
federal government,
so they can feed
themselves. Public Works
Administration, the Works
Progress Administration,
the PWA turns into the
WPA, doing work on public
projects. Social
Security is established,
the Securities and Exchange
Commission is established,
the FDIC, the
Federal Emergency Relief
Administration. All of
these are brand new during
this era. So what we
consider the essential work
of the federal
government is,
in our contemporary moment
is essentially created
during the New Deal. All is
a radical attempt to end the
Great Depression. And
we have been wrestling,
we, political
leaders, activists,
have been wrestling with the
legacy of the New Deal ever
since. Now the point
of listing all of these
agencies up here is not just
that many of these had a
direct effect on African
American employment and,
as you'll see,
political possibility,
but it also will
bring into--I'm sort of
for--projecting here a
bit--it will underscore
changes--how can I...not
changes--articulations,
new articulations of changes
in terms of the limits of
the federal government.
We'll see during our lecture
of the civil
rights movement,
there's a core issue and
that's the fed--limits of
federal government versus
states' government. With
the explosion in the size
of the federal government,
you can see this problem
looming ever larger on the
horizon. Now very
basic questions,
was the New Deal
successful? It's all an
experiment.
And economically,
the answer is mixed.
Yes, there is no doubt,
it saved millions
from starvation,
I mean, literally saving
folks from starving to
death. But the economy
doesn't actually turn around
until the U.S.
begins arming Europe as it
heads toward Second World
War. When the U.S.
becomes a military factory
and then itself becomes
involved in the
Second World War,
that's when the economy
turns--absolutely booms and
it turns around at that
point. So economically it
saves people from starving
but it doesn't turn the
economy
around. Politically,
it's much more complicated.
From an institutional
standpoint, there's no
doubt that the New Deal's
significant. Whether it's
successful I guess might be
an interesting word to
wrest with here because,
as I said before, it
makes the modern American
political state. It does it
in the space of just a few
years. Now from the
standpoint of the African
American experience, was the
New Deal successful in terms
of politics here?
There's a real mixed record.
On the ground, too many
federal programs were left
to local
administrators to run.
So you have--and this is
where something like the
Farm Security
Administration,
Agricultural
Administration--Adjustment
Administration, are really
important. Federal policy
is saying you're not
going to discriminate.
Everybody's going to get a
sh--a cut of this New Deal.
But the bailouts are handed
out at the local level,
at the local Farm
Bureau, let's say,
and localized racial
practices simply just don't
disappear. So you have
growing out of the New Deal,
or during the New Deal,
American farms being saved,
but the farms that are being
saved overwhelmingly are
those that are white-owned
and not black-owned. So
when you think of the New
Deal from the standpoint of
did it benefit
African Americans,
you can look at federal--at,
at the sort of national
policy and see something,
non-discrimination pacts,
but local level's
where it really matters,
you see a very different
story there. Now just as
some of these--many of these
New Deal programs were doing
something important by being
non-discriminatory in their
language, and then therefore
at the local level being
more complicated, they
weren't all perfect at the
federal level of
articulation. And this is
where the NRA, the National
Recovery Administration,
really needs to be
understood. As I said
before, the NRA designed
a set of minimum wages,
basically wage standards,
across the country. So,
for instance, if you
are rolling steel,
you're going to get paid a
certain minimum wage. If
you are--boy, of the
billion and a half jobs,
I can't think of
anything right now. If
you're--[laughs] God, pick
a job--you are doing some
other mechanized thing,
how's that for a complete
bailout? You're going
to get paid a certain set
wage. Now the reason
I was flailing here,
because there are certain
areas the NRA doesn't
address the minimum wage,
and I kept wanting to say
those things; That's why I
was fumbling. It does not
establish minimum wages
for people in agricultural
sector. It does not set
minimum wages for people
doing domestic work. Guess
what African Americans are
mostly employed in:
agricultural work and
domestic work. Now there
are all kinds of reasons
that people who conceived
the NRA had for not putting
floors at, at certain wages
for certain industries,
agriculture and domestic
work in this case. They
weren't
explicitly about, "Oh,
let's stick it to these
people." But the fact was,
the effect was, they were
sticking it to these people,
to farmers in general and to
people doing domestic work.
The NRA then becomes a
symbol for how little the
New Deal was doing for black
America. Long term effects,
there's no doubt,
very important,
and we'll see that in
the next couple of weeks,
from the concept of what the
federal government is. From
an institutional standpoint,
there's no doubt,
it's important,
it's critical,
it's saving lives. When it
comes to black life on the
ground, a mixed bag.
When it comes to NRA, which
had really more power than
any other of these
administrations to change
the quality of black life,
to sort of bolster it up,
no dice. So African
Americans start calling the
National Recovery
Administration,
the letters NRA, referred
to as Negro Rights Abused,
Negro Rights Assassinated,
Negro Removal Act,
Negroes Ruined Again.
Now we're talking bread and
butter issues here. But
politics of course exist at
the symbolic level, and
when it comes to African
Americans, there is no
doubt that symbolically,
the New Deal was an
overwhelming success. The
political symbolism of the
New Deal for blacks came
mostly through the
establishment of a group
called the Federal
Council on Negro Affairs,
the Black Cabinet. They're
the same thing. The Black
Cabinet was an
unofficial--it's important
to understand that part--an
unofficial collection of
race advisors, and
that was their title,
who stood in various
places in Roosevelt's
administration.
This was the first
broad-based group of
federally
appointed bureaucrats and
administrators who
were African American,
at the federal
government--in the federal
government's history.
Prior to this moment,
you might have Frederick
Douglass appointed to
federal position, Booker T.
Washington being consulted
by the President about
certain kinds of ideas and
policies. But in the New
Deal, you're
actually getting a,
a cadre of African Americans
with federal appointments,
working within the
administration on a
full-time basis. The
members of the Black Cabinet
were all highly-educated
and all male,
with the lone exception
of Mary McLeod Bethune,
who was the one, well,
one female. Seems my,
there we go. Mary McLeod
Bethune. And the spelling
is correct and the
pronunciation's correct,
it's "McCloud."
Mary McLeod Bethune,
the sole female in
the Black Cabinet,
who also happened to be
regarded as the cabinet's
leader. Now the
Cabinet, the Black Cabinet,
leaves no discernible policy
record or legacy. Their
job, the job, the
things they did were mainly
accomplished
behind the scenes.
And, in fact,
I, I know this,
this--I planned to write my
dissertation on the Black
Cabinet, only to
discover, once I got here,
there was no record. So,
new dissertation topic.
Their job was mainly
conducted behind the scenes,
so you'd have a
Secretary of the Interior,
or a Secretary
of Agriculture,
wanting to, you know, find
out what's going on with
black America.
They have a race advisor,
and they would assign
him--overwhelmingly
him, of course,
except for Mary McLeod
Bethune--the task of finding
out, or being the,
the touchstone to,
to understand what's
happening in black America.
And there might be
an issue bubbling up,
say in the National
Parks or some other place,
that the race
advisor might know about,
and would put sort of a
bug in his boss's ear,
and it might gently change
administration policy,
or maybe even law that way.
But we don't actually know
the literal changes they
made. But we do know that
they were very important
symbolically. And the most
important person
symbolically in this regard
is Mary McLeod
Bethune. Bethune,
who's the head of the
Negro Youth Division of the
National Youth
Administration,
an educator,
lifelong educator,
and then, most importantly,
a close friend of the first
lady, Eleanor
Roosevelt. Bethune is seen,
seen to be the voice of
black America in so many
ways, in this,
in this, in the,
the Black Cabinet, that is,
because she had access. And
there was--it was op--it was
not a secret. It was well
known that if you wanted to
talk to Franklin Roosevelt
and you're African American,
you had to go through
Eleanor Roosevelt, and
if you wanted to talk to
Eleanor Roosevelt, you had
to go through Mary McLeod
Bethune to get access. So
the Black Cabinet needs to
be understood as the first
political insiders in black
America, and I'm talking
high politics here. This is
an era where the Black
Cabinet officers would be
trotted out.
Pictures of them,
or sometimes
themselves literally,
trotted out, sent on sort of
as part of a delegation to a
particular area of
town, the country,
representing the federal
government to a black
enclave. And they were seen
as embodying the fact that
Roosevelt cared. Whether
you're talking Mary McLeod
Bethune or somebody else,
Roosevelt cared because he
had people appointed to
express or deal with,
address their concerns.
This is how they're
symbolically so important,
and it's also important to
know that over the
course of the 1930s,
during FDR's presidency,
through the interventions of
the New Deal,
sometimes literally,
most often symbolically,
African Americans turn from
a Republican
voting population to a
Democrat--Democratic voting
population. A complete
shift by the time you get to
the late 1930s. The Black
Cabinet's important in that
process. Now just as you're
seeing the establishment
of the first sort of
professional
administrators, bureaucrats,
African American, in
the federal government,
certainly at high level,
there is--this is also an
era of incredible political
setback and disappointment.
So you see the great
political possibility of the
Black Cabinet, but you also
see events happening in the
early 1930s that horrify
black America. The most
famous of these cases
was the Scottsboro Boys
scandal. On
March 25th, 1931,
a white boy comes
off of a train,
passing through Tennessee
and the northern tips of
Alabama. He comes off the
train with a bloody head and
claims that there was a
big fight between black and
white boys on his freight
train that just passed
through town. A posse
forms. The train is stopped
at the next station. The
posse looks for and arrests
the nine black boys who
happen to be on the freight
train. Now what the posse
had not expected--and that
would have been the
end of the story,
if that was all that had
happened. What the posse
had not expected to
find were two white women,
Ruby Bates and Victoria
Price. And they were found
in the same freight car as
some of the black boys. As
soon as Ruby Bates and
Victoria Price are brought
out, they see all of the
police and the posse around
them, and they're
with these black boys,
they immediately size up
the situation and declare
they've been raped. This
changes everything. The
nine boys are
accused of rape,
become known as the
Scottsboro Boys. That's
where the, the court
cases were being held,
in Scottsboro, Alabama.
They range in age from
twenty to thirteen. There
were one or two brother
pairs, but they
didn't know each other,
essentially. They all
happened to be there. But
word of the rape
spreads like wildfire,
and the next day, a mob of
two thousand people forms at
the jail where
they'd been kept,
urging the release
of the Boys so that,
quote, "southern justice"
could be handed out. The
National Guard is called
in immediately to keep them
safe, which is remarkable
in and of itself. The media
does not help
matters when it,
when it comes to this
particular case and the fact
that, you know, the word of
this vicious attack starts
to spread. As they start
the process of sending the
Boys to trial, the
media, several quotes from
different newspapers:
"How much farther apart than
night and day are the nine
men who perpetrated these
frightful deeds
and a normal,
kind hearted man who guards
his little family and toils
through the day?"
Okay, not too offensive.
"We still have
savages abroad in the land,
it seems. Let us have the
solace of knowing that at
least we have risen above
this justice of savages."
A reference to
the fact that,
that the mob that wanted to
kill the Scottsboro Boys did
not succeed. So
with an editorial,
giving a collective pat on
the back to folks who did
not resort to the same kind
of savagery those boys did.
But then you'd have
editorials like this: "The
rape was the most atrocious
ever recorded in this part
of the country, a wholesale
debauching of society,
so horrible in its details
that all of the facts can
never be printed. It
savors of the jungle and the
meanest African corruption."
This is pre-trial media.
Not very helpful for a
defense case. At seven A.M.
on the day of
the first trial,
thousands are lined
up, trying to get a seat
inside. And you--it's
hard--you can't really tell
from this image, but as the,
the group goes this way,
you can see it where the
electric lines are cutting
across, the line
goes beyond the screen,
beyond the, the actual
image. Thousands are lined
up hoping to get into the
courthouse to see justice be
enacted. Well, the
boys had no money,
they're dirt poor. They
have a defense attorney
assigned to them who's
completely incompetent.
They face an all-white
jury. This is Alabama
practice. No blacks are
allowed in the jury rolls.
And, within two weeks,
the boys are indicted,
tried, and all but one are
sentenced to death. The
nature of the defense,
the speed of the trial,
the fact that it was not
a jury of their peers,
angered African Americans
and other parties. One
party got--was moved
to act very quickly,
and that's a group called
the International Labor
Defense, the ILD. The
ILD is the legal arm of the
Communist Party, and the
ILD comes to the Scottsboro
Boys'--Boys'
rescue immediately,
claiming they were given
an inadequate defense,
and all these different
things already cited. "This
was not justice; you need
to have a retrial." Now the
Communist Party in the USA
has been around since 1919
or so. It's been reaching
out in sort of tentative
ways to African
Americans, with,
with, you know,
middling success really,
increasing but middling.
The NAACP's been around a
solid decade longer, so one
would presume they're right
there rushing to
defend them. Well,
the fact is, no. The NAACP
holds back. It holds back
for a very important
reason. It did not want to
tar its own image by
defending possible rapists
and individuals who clearly
did not adhere to the
NAACP's middle class
ideals. This is really
important to think about--to
understand about the NAACP.
It was from its very
founding a middle class
organization, dedicated to
uplift in legalistic and
political ways,
assimilationist in its
ideology,
assimilating to white norms,
white--so-called white
middle class norms. The
Scottsboro Boys did
not fit that model,
and the NAACP was afraid of
defending them for fear of a
negative association. The
Communist Party sees this as
an, an
incredible opportunity,
as a way to organize African
Americans to become more
sympathetic to the Communist
Party. The Communist Party
claimed that defending
the Scottsboro Boys was
tantamount to fighting
Southern racism and economic
repression. So the
Communists did not have
super success with
African Americans,
because they were
saying it's all just about
economics. And African
Americans are saying,
"Well, race kind of matters
too in this country." The
Scottsboro Boys was the, was
the window of opportunity
for the Communist Party to
broaden the scope of what
it's going to talk about as
it relates to the African
American experience. This
transpires and the NAACP's
livid. It wants to be
the organization really
dedicated to
addressing black concerns,
and it's very concerned
that the Communist Party is
involved, because the
radicalism of the Communist
Party was, was the, was
about the last thing that's
going to be welcomed in a
politically and socially
conservative South. So the
NAACP doesn't want to get
involved because it--it
would be tarnished by these
Boys' activities, but they
also recognized that with
the Communist Party
getting involved,
it might be a death, a death
sentence for these Boys,
because no one wants to hear
from the Communists. And
certainly as the Communists
saw this as a way to open up
a discussion about
Southern racism,
NAACP thought
that, you know,
"You're, you're pulling too
many things together here,
and trying to--basically
you're trying to develop
racial insubordination in
the South. This is not the
way to go." The Scottsboro
Boys' case because--becomes
the cause célèbre of the
1930s. All of the issues
we've talked about in this
course so far are wrapped up
in this history:
manliness, civilization,
culture, race,
class, power, politics,
and protest, they're all
here. The NAACP wanted more
than anything else
for a fair trial,
and began to think,
"Well, maybe we should get
involved, because we might
be able to win long-term
advantage for African
Americans by changing the
way that trials are
organized in the South,
since there were no
blacks on the jury rolls;
that might help further
legal challenges and other
movement opportunities
down the--down the road.
And the NAACP, you know
on a quick side story,
it knows the
South very well,
far better than
the Communists did,
who were mostly northern and
urban at this point. And
they reach out, the NAACP
reaches out quietly to try
to find lawyers for the
Scottsboro Boys who are
competent. And they talked
to George--Congressman
George Huddleston, someone
Alabamans considered a fiery
left-winger. But being
liberal on white issues in
the South did not
necessarily translate into
being a liberal on,
quote, "black issues" here.
Huddleston's response to
the quiet overture from the
NAACP to support the
Scottsboro Boys' defense,
and I quote here, "I do
not care whether they are
innocent or guilty. You
can't understand how we
Southern gentlemen feel
about this--this question of
relationship between
Negro men and white women."
Simply put, the fact
that the Boys were on the
freight--the same train
as the two white girls was
enough for Huddleston.
He couldn't touch it; it's
toxic. So the very basic
chronology of the
case is as follows.
In 1931, the Boys were
arrested and convicted. In
1932, the Supreme Court
overturns their convictions,
saying the Boys lacked
adequate counsel. The fact
that they're still alive is
really nothing short of a
miracle, to be honest, and
this is through the ILD's
efforts. In
1930--in February 1933,
Ruby Bates, one of the two
women who was found on the,
the train, writes a letter
declaring that the boys
never touched her, that's
it's all made up to protect
their honor. A month later,
a new trial begins and
Samuel Leibowitz, an ILD
attorney from New York,
offers new evidence, but is
considered to have been too
tough on
Victoria Price, the,
the hold out.
And to her, to her
death, she claimed that this
was--that she had been
raped. Samuel Leibowitz
presents new evidence, but
was considered too tough on
Victoria Price, thus
violating Southern codes of
honor. After one
day of deliberation,
Haywood Patterson, one
of the Scottsboro Boys,
is found guilty. The
prosecutor is saying openly,
"Show them that Alabama
justice cannot be bought and
sold with Jew money from
New York." This is the
atmosphere of this case.
NAACP blames the I--the
Communist Party and the
ILD for this conviction and
that--and at that
point realizes,
or decides, they have to get
involved if they're going
to--if there's going to be
any hope of saving the rest
of the boys. By 1935, the
ILD and NAACP are formed
together in a coalition
to defend the Boys. The
Communist Party's actions
through all of this gave it
a new base of intellectual
and political support,
within Harlem certainly, and
black America in general.
The Scottsboro Boys'
mothers go on a world tour,
supported by the
Communist Party,
to rally support
for their sons,
but also for
workers' plights,
for workers' plights around
the world. And this is
really--this point is
important. The Communist
Party makes major inroads
in Harlem in particular,
and you can see
here in this image,
this is a Scottsboro Boys
rally. And above my hand
here there's a big
sign, a big poster,
and the words you can make
out there is talking about
workers, and below it,
Scottsboro Boys. The
Scottsboro Boys
themselves were,
were vagabonds,
hobos riding the rails,
not uncommon during
this period in time. The
Communist Party gets
involved and as a way to
sort of justify its
involvement certainly,
but also to rally other
people around the cause of
the Scottsboro Boys, starts
talking about them as,
as workers. "This is what
happens to workers in the
United States under a
capitalist system." The
Scottsboro Boys' mothers are
sent on these international
world tours and they're
coached about how they're
going to talk about
the worker's plight,
that the Communist Party
cares about the workers of
the world, and at the end,
it's a demonstration--it's,
it's proven by the way that
they're advocating on behalf
of their boys. As we start
to learn more about the
Scottsboro Boys'
mothers' tour,
their world tours, we're
discovering the extent to
which they were--manipulated
is too strong a word--but
how they were so
highly scripted,
the mothers that is, in
terms of what they were
supposed to say and not say
and how they were being sort
of handled at all times to
make sure they stayed on
message. Now, be
that as it may,
whether there was a level
of manipulation here or not,
the fact is the Communist
Party is making incredible
efforts on behalf of
the Scottsboro Boys,
and the case is followed
everywhere. And this
actually--This is actually
another image from Harlem.
And this--I'm sorry you
can't really make it out
here, but in a
sense, this is a,
a, a version now of what
you'd see--what do they call
those things in
Times Square,
those scrolling messages?
This is an update on the
trial, when Patterson is
found guilty. And there's a
commentary written down in
chalk on this blackboard.
People are gathered
around it to find out what's
happening with the
Scottsboro Boys. Now what
happens to them?
They get arrested '31,
a new case in, in
'32. New cases in '33,
in '33, a coalition in '35.
More hearings were held.
Half the Boys are released
within a few years of the
original incident. The
other half languish behind
bars, and the last one,
the last Scottsboro Boy is
released, no longer a boy,
in 1950. The Scottsboro
Boys' cause became the focal
point of rallies across the
country, in Harlem,
as these images show,
black college campuses.
The Scottsboro Boys' cause
became the sites of
numerous political protests,
and it really speaks to the
new era or new philosophy
about black politics during
this era. These rallies are
not the rallies of Garvey's
Back to Africa dreams.
They're not the
silent protest marches,
protesting against
lynchings. The Scottsboro
Boys' rallies, although they
are rich in symbolism about
the black--the black
Boys being workers,
they also start to change
political affiliations and
movements on the ground.
The Scottsboro Boys' rallies
are, in so many ways,
explicitly political. And
these rallies, in this
way, are new to the,
to the scene as far--far
as black Americans were
concerned. And we'll see
how this is articulated in
movement politics in--in
our next lecture. So taking
together the Black Cabinet
and the Scottsboro Boys'
case, represent two sides of
new political possibilities
and new forms of political
expression within black
America: high politics and,
for lack of a better phrase,
the low politics, but
also becoming topics of
international conversation
in terms of the black
political situation. It's
a time of change. Oh one
image here I forgot, before
I tell a quick story. This
is a poster. I mean the
Scottsboro Boys went on
tour.
In 1937, Willie Robinson and
Eugene Williams came to New
Haven to tell of the
"horrors of hell and the
pleasures of heaven." They
came to the Emanuel Baptist
Church to talk about
their experiences in,
in, Scotts--in the, in this
case. It's a local story in
this way, but it's part
of a larger international
phenomenon. Now I want to
switch gears quickly from
the Black Cabinet and the
Scottsboro Boys to talk of
the New Negro Alliance. And
I've got six minutes to tell
what I used to
do in a lecture,
so hang on. The New
Negro Alliance is a local
articulation--this is
local being Washington,
D.C.--of a larger
national phenomenon,
"Don't buy where you can't
work" campaigns. "Don't buy
where you can't work"
campaigns. And it speaks to
this new sort of form of
political organizing that
I'm suggesting is there with
the Scottsboro Boys and the,
the Black Cabinet. So I've
seen certain ways the New
Negro Alliance pulling
together embodying this new
political philosophy.
That's why I want to tell
this story very quickly.
So there are these campaigns
across the country where
black--blacks would
organize and say,
"We're not going to buy
at the local thrift store,
because they won't employ
black workers in this black
neighborhood. In
August of 1933,
this philosophy, this
political movement,
lands in D.C.
where the owner of the local
hamburger stand in black
Washington, in, in the
area, U Street district near
Howard--Howard University,
sort of the major black
shopping enclave in the
city. When the the guy who
owns the hamburger grill
fires the two black workers
he has and hires two
white kids in his place,
wants to give them
jobs. You know,
everybody's desperate for
jobs since it's the Great
Depression. Within hours, a
picket line's formed at the
hamburger stand, in the
spirit of "Don't buy where
you can't work." "We're not
going to patronize the store
anymore, because they
won't let our type,
our folks, black folks, work
in this place." And this is
a white-owned store, if
that part wasn't clear. It
should have been.
Next thing you know,
an--a group is organized.
Two or three young men in
college, just
heading out of college,
called the New Negro
Alliance. One of these
"Don't buy where you
can't work" campaigns,
and the city
becomes electrified,
black
Wash--Washington that is,
as New Negro--New Negro
Alliance starts holding
rallies, putting up
posters. This is about
staying out of People's
drugstores. You know,
"They won't employ
blacks in the store,
we're not going to shop
there any longer." To all
fine--to all
fair-minded people,
justice is, is essential to
Americanism. People's is
not just being
racist; they're being
anti-American. Other
pair--posters would go up,
fliers, again, about
People's Drugstore. "Don't
cheat on your race.
Stay out of all People's
Drugstores." And so
equating People's Drugstores
to an overseer whipping a
poor black laborer. Now
this is sort of the
angry political art of a,
you know,
college-age students.
You know how you guys are.
But the New Negro Alliance
really became remarkable for
the way that it brought in
all these
different sectors of,
of black Washington. The
most respectable members of
Washington start joining
picket lines. "People's is
unfair, no colored clerks in
colored neighborhoods. Stay
out." In short order, the
New Negro Alliance starts
getting success after
success. The local dairy,
People's
Drugstore, the cigar shop,
all these places start
to hire black workers,
but there's a hold out.
The hold out is the Sanitary
Grocery Company. The
Sanitary Grocery Company is
the most important
grocer in Washington,
D.C., during the era. It's
in black neighborhoods and
white neighborhoods.
Sanitary Grocery employed
black workers, but as
back office workers,
stockroom boys, or
janitors. These were the
lowest paying jobs in the
store and they were also the
invisible jobs. New Negro
Alliance comes up to them
and says, you know, "The
best paying jobs in your
store, aside from
being managers,
are the cash register
clerks. Why don't you have
any blacks in those
positions?" Sanitary
Grocery gave
its explanation,
gave its reasons, and the
New Negro Alliance puts up
picket lines like this one.
This is just one person,
but starts putting up
picket lines around Sanitary
Grocery. Sanitary Grocery
is not going to fold like
these other places fold, and
so starts its own political
campaign with photographs
of all the black workers,
you know, dressed
in nice uniforms,
smiling for the
camera. You know,
"Sanitary Grocery
works--you know,
we work for
Sanitary Grocery,
support Sanitary Grocery."
So they're trading fliers,
pamphlets, media bout--you
know media shots for a--for
a long time. It starts
becoming a legal case. The
New Negro Alliance activists
reach out to Howard
University Law School. This
is a pre--pro--prologue to
the lecture next week.
They reach out to Howard
University Law School,
and says to the law school
students, "We need help
organizing a court case
here." And they start
getting legal counsel from
some of the law students and
some of the law professors.
Because it's in D.C., a
court case can become a
Supreme Court case very
quickly. The le--the
issue--the legal issue,
Sanitary Grocery Company is
saying, "You cannot picket
in front of our store.
You're not an employee."
Just like this minister is
picketing in front of
People's. He didn't work at
People's. Sanitary Grocery
is go--Sanitary Grocery is
saying, "If you don't--if
you aren't an employee of
the company, you aren't
allowed to picket." New
Negro Alliance said, "This
is a free speech issue. We
can picket." And it becomes
a Supreme Court case. And
in 1938, aided by the
attorneys at--the attorneys
in training and the, the
faculty at the law school at
Howard, the Supreme Court
offers a decision in The New
Negro Alliance versus
Sanitary Grocery Company.
And in that decision, it
says that it's protected
speech, picketing that
is. As long as you're not
interfering with the
business at hand in terms of
blocking the
entrance, let's say,
it's protected
speech. And as such,
these rallies, these--the
work of the New Negro
Alliance, is perfectly
constitutional. It's a
major boost to
the labor movement,
as it happens, and it really
makes great changes for the
New Negro
Alliance. It further,
you know,
underscores its importance.
It also tells a really
interesting story at the
end. There's a coda that I
think is really humorous,
but tells you something
about the way these things
operate. Sanitary
Grocery Company was the most
important
grocer in the city,
and the last thing it
wanted or needed was to be
affiliated with a Supreme
Court case that it lost,
especially losing to African
Americans. So the Sanitary
Grocery Company ceases doing
business under that name,
and it becomes Safeway. For
those of you who know about
Safeway, yes. I mean
Safeways are actually
disappearing now, because
they're being bought up by
other conglomerates,
but Safeway's a major
chain--well, last I knew,
still a major chain in--in
California. And
they're still in the D.C.
area, although they
are slowly going away,
being bought up by,
last time I checked,
which is a
couple of years ago,
it was--it was owned by the
parent company of--that also
owned Vond's,
Pavilion's, Dominic's,
Carr's,
Randall's, Tom Thumb's,
Grocery Works. I
think it's a big Canadian
conglomerate. But this is,
I mean it's a humorous coda
for those who know Safeway.
There's no mention anywhere
of Safeway's
history, corporate history,
of this actual--actually
happening. Corporations
don't want to
be tainted with,
well, lack of success or
really bad news. And in the
case of the "Don't buy where
you can't work" campaign in
Washington, D.C., they
had both. And so Sanitary
Grocery Company ceased to
exist. It started operating
under a new name. This is
the potential of the new
black politics:
high politics,
low politics, somewhere
in the middle politics,
and you're going to start
seeing in tomorrow's lecture
and in the, in the lectures
over the next couple of
weeks, a new kind of
organizing mentality,
operating at all levels,
that starts to change the
landscape of the American
scene. Thanks so much.